I've talked a bunch
about the Drake equation,
or our own version
of the Drake equation
that starts with the number
of stars in the galaxy,
but I haven't given
it a shot yet.
I haven't tried my own
attempt at thinking
about how many detectable
civilizations there are.
So let's actually do that here.
So let's just assume that
there are 100 billion stars.
100 billion stars.
So that's my first
term right over there.
Let's say that 1/4
will develop planets.
And let's say of the solar
systems that develop planets,
on average let's say
that they develop
an average of 0.1 planets
capable of sustaining life.
Or really, that you'll have
one planet for every 10
of these solar
systems with planets.
That's just my assumption there.
I don't know if that's right.
Now let's multiply
that times the fraction
of these planets
capable of sustaining
life that actually
will get life.
And I don't know what that is,
but I hinted in previous videos
that life is one of
those things that it
seems like if you have
all the right ingredients,
it's so robust.
And you have life it these
underwater volcanoes,
you have bacteria
that can process
all sorts of weird things.
So let's say that
probability is pretty high.
Let's say that is 50%,
or half of the plans that
are capable of getting
life actually do have life.
I would guess that that
might even be higher.
But once again, just a guess.
Now we have to think
about of the life, what
fraction becomes intelligent?
What becomes intelligent over
some point in the history?
Well, I'll say it's a tenth.
A tenth of all--
maybe if the asteroids
didn't kill the
dinosaurs, it wouldn't
have happened on Earth.
Who knows?
Or maybe we'd just have some
very intelligent dinosaurs
around.
We don't know.
And maybe there's other
forms of intelligent life
even on our own planet that
we haven't fully appreciated.
Dolphins are a good candidate.
Some people believe
that octopuses,
because they have
such flexible arms,
there's a theory that they
could develop eventually
the ability to kind one
day, if their brains mature,
and all of the rest, make tools
the same way primitive primates
eventually were able to
have larger brain sizes
and actually manipulate
things to make tools.
So who knows?
I don't want to get
into all of that.
So there's a 1 in 10 chance
that you get intelligent life,
and then assuming that
intelligent life shows up,
what fraction is going
to become detectable?
I don't know.
I don't know whether dolphins
will ever communicate via radio
or not.
So let's just say that
is-- I don't know.
Let's say that is another 1
in 10 chance, or I'll say 0.1.
And then we have to multiply
it times the detectable life
of the civilization on average.
Once again, huge
assumptions being
here, but the detectable
life of a civilization,
let me just put it
at 10,000 years.
Either they destroy
themselves, or they
get beyond that type of
radio type communication,
electromagnetic
type communication.
Maybe they start doing all
sorts of weird, wacky things.
Probably it won't
take you 10,000 years
to even progress it.
That might take you less time.
But let's just do this
just for the sake of fun.
And then the lifespan
of your average star,
that's probably
one of the things
that we have the best sense of.
So on average, let's put
it at 10 billion years,
10 billion years.
So let's calculate all of this.
Let's get my handy TI-85 out.
And so we're going
to have 100 billion.
That's 1 times 10 to the 9th.
Sorry, that's 100
times 10 to the ninth.
So let me clear it.
Or you could have 1
times 10 to the 11th.
That is 100 billion times
0.25 times 0.1 times .05 times
0.1 again, times 0.1
again, times 10,000
divided by 10 billion.
So times 10,000, 1, 2,
3, divided by 10 billion.
So that's one 1e10.
1 times 10 to the 10th power.
1 with 10 zeroes.
So let's see what we get.
We get 12.5, which is
kind of a neat number,
but these are heavily
dependent on this.
So we're saying if
given these assumptions,
there should be 12.5
detectable civilizations
in our galaxy right now.
So the question is, why
aren't we detecting it?
Maybe their radio signals, maybe
their electromagnetic waves
are getting to us, but we can't
differentiate it from noise
right now.
And that's what the whole
SETI project's all about,
of trying to keep track
of all this information,
all of these radio waves, and
electromagnetic waves that
are coming from outer
space towards Earth,
and seeing if any of them
actually have any non noise
signal, that actually look
like they're being generated
by some type of
intelligent civilization.
So maybe we're getting them, and
we're just not detecting them,
or maybe something
else is at play.
Maybe we've overestimated
one of these.
Maybe there is a lot a
life, but maybe they're
not using electromagnetic
waves to communicate.
Maybe that's some type of
primitive way of communicating.
Maybe they start doing
telepathy, or something crazy,
or they start using some
type of quantum thing
that allows them to communicate
more directly without having
to wait for the speed of light.
That is a very slow
way to communicate.
And it is a slow way,
frankly, if you're
trying to communicate
across solar systems,
and stars, and planets,
or even across galaxies,
one could imagine.
So maybe we're just kind
of at a transition state
of communication, that
electromagnetic waves, radio
and all the rest is
just a transition state.
Maybe in 100 years
we'll figure out
another, better way
that's not detectable
in our traditional ways.
Maybe we're being bombarded with
another type of communication
mechanism that we're just
not ready to perceive yet.
Who knows, but it's just
a fun thought experiment
to say that hey, given
these assumptions,
there should be at least
a couple of civilizations,
or a handful of
civilizations that we
might be able to detect.